in our last episode we covered adjusting
routing storing and viewing logs from
your services and cloud logging but what
else can you do with all that data
today i'm going to show you how you can
use cloud logging to further improve
your ability to keep your services
reliable with features like alerting on
logs logs based metrics and capturing
application exceptions in error
reporting welcome to engineering for
reliability with google cloud
let's say you're running a production
environment and you need to know if any
modifications are made to the im
configuration for this project
these changes will show up in audit logs
we don't really want to sift through
those to figure out when something like
this happens
you could set up a rudimentary log
processing pipeline with cloud functions
but now there's an easier way let's have
a look at how to use the new log based
alerts in cloud logging
from the dashboard go to the products
menu
and from logging select logs explorer
we want to find all logs that show
changes in im policies that's easy
enough to do using recent queries
once we have the logs we want to alert
on we can use the actions button to
create a log alert
let's name our alert
and add any information we want to send
with the alert
next let's confirm our logs query
then let's set the minimum time between
notifications to be as frequent as we'd
like
finally let's specify the notification
channel and save the alert
the alerting policy has been created and
we are ready to test it
if an iam policy change is made
we can go back to logging and rerun the
query to see that more entries matching
our equity are available
from there we can go to monitoring
and select
alerting there's a current incident
based on the alerting policy we created
we can select the incident to confirm
that we have a log query match that
triggered our condition
we can click view logs to see the logs
that generated the match and the alert
so that's how you can use log base alert
policies to be notified when for example
there's a change in im configuration in
your project
alerting on logs is great but what if
you want to know how many times
something like this happens or what if
the log payloads of data in them that
you'd like to measure over time
this is where logs based metrics come in
you can configure a counter metric to
measure the permanent rate of log
entries that match a query or a
distribution metric to capture numeric
values from log enter payloads let's
have a look at how to set up a counter
metric in cloud logging and use it in
cloud monitoring
let's create a metric to count requests
to our service running an app engine
labeled by response code
let's go to the logs explorer
and select our google app engine
application
let's select an entry that shows an app
engine request and use show matching
entries to get all the logs that look
like what we want to include as a source
for our metric
we'll again use the actions button but
this time we'll create a metric
we'll select counter as the metric type
and name our metric
next we'll confirm the filter and add a
label to our metric that will allow us
to separate request counts by status
finally let's save the metric
now when we go to log base metrics we
can see our metric here
once a metric is created and gathering
data we can use it like any other
monitoring metric
we can view it in metrics explorer we
can use it for charts and dashboards and
we can even create alerts using it in a
condition so that's how you can use a
counter log base metric to count app
engine requests labeled by response code
status
we've now seen how to get alerts on logs
and how to use them to create metrics
the last thing i want to show you is how
to use error reporting to count analyze
and aggregate the crashes in your
running cloud services let's have a look
from the products menu go to error
reporting
the initial screen shows you a summary
of all the errors that have been seen in
your project over the selected time
interval you can click on an error to
get more information about it
the histogram will show you how
frequently this error has occurred
further down you can see the parsed and
raw stack traces and the specific
samples of the error
you can even view the logs that
generated that particular sample by
viewing the logs for the sample you can
see information about where the error
originated
here we can see the gke cluster
namespace and container that through
this particular exception so error
reporting is a great way to see
application exceptions in your services
and quickly figure out when they're
happening and where they're coming from
services running on app engine or cloud
run send errors to error reporting
automatically
you can send errors from other
applications to air reporting by logging
to cloud logging in a format
recognizable by error reporting or by
using the air reporting api directly
refer to the documentation for details
on both of those options
thanks for joining me today we covered
alerting our log entries using logs
based metrics to count and aggregate log
entries and using error reporting track
application crashes
i hope these features help you find
issues faster and keep your services
reliable and your users happy thanks so
much for watching don't forget to like
and subscribe to never miss out on more
engineering for reliability with google
cloud see you soon
you